misuk video is raising still more
questions in the investigation of the
federal jail cell death of convicted sex
offender Jeffrey Epstein federal
prosecutors said yesterday video of
Epstein's jail cell when he made his
first suicide attempt no longer exists
that's a quote
Epstein died by suicide weeks later on
August 10th the well-connected 66 year
old was accused of sexually abusing
dozens of underage girls while that
lanky reports on the growing criticism
of the jail where Epstein was held a
recent 60 minutes broadcast shows the
New York jail cell where Jeffrey Epstein
hanged himself last August but now
there's new focus on the suicide attempt
Epstein made weeks before he died
video of the cell exterior where Epstein
first tried to end his life was sent to
federal investigators and restored last
week but on Thursday prosecutors said
it's the wrong video
in a letter federal prosecutors said the
jail inadvertently preserved video from
the wrong tear at the jail and as a
result video from outside the defendants
cell no longer exists CBS News legal
analyst Rickey Kleeman when I read this
letter I had to reread it because I said
this just can't be happening this is
madness Nicholas Tartaglia was epstein
cellmate at the Metropolitan
Correctional Centre for the weeks
between Epstein's July arrest and his
first suicide attempt Bruce barqueta
start tag Leone's attorney it is the
worst facility jail or prison that I've
been to in 35 years of practicing law
the missing jail cell video could
reignite speculation of a cover-up as
the detention facility continues to be
under fire for multiple failures before
Epstein died in custody when you've got
videotaped disappearing camera is not
working
guards allegedly not being where they're
supposed to be it's no wonder that
Jeffrey Epstein is dead these things can
happen right these things can happen but
they all shouldn't happen in one place
hey mol eggy is outside the facility in
New York City bola good morning these
things can happen but all of them have
what did the jail have to say about this
lost video well Toni they've had nothing
to say so far to us when we've reached
out to them the MCC through the Bureau
of Prisons which of course oversees the
MCC declined to comment citing the
ongoing investigation into Geoffrey
Epstein's death which really comes as no
surprise the Bo P has remained silent on
all things epstein throughout the course
of this investigation into Geoffrey
Epstein's death which by the way Tony
five months ago today Epstein died thank
you very much we should remember the
stakes here I mean well it's an almost
incomprehensible series of coincidences
as you will III thought Ricky was dead
on summing it up as she always is we
just said she when she said it's
maddening number one it's very
suspicious and when she also said all
these things can happen but in one place
time after time a lot of questions there
you